the most dangerous dog breeder we could
ever think of the American Bully XL
there's been a 50 increase in Hospital
admissions in the UK for dog bites
what's going on here over the last five
years and in particular last two years
there's been a big Rise
um both in fatalities which are still
relatively small but also injuries and a
huge amounts of this is down to one
particular breed which is related to
both the Staffordshire Bull Terrier and
the pit bull with the pit bulls you know
is banned in Britain but has managed to
avoid being classified under the
dangerous dogs act and has become
increasingly popular and many people
will notice these dogs in their area
these are kind of very very big like
double or staffy almost in some ways
lots of the people who run all sort of
like dog charities in the Kennel Club
are completely in denial about the link
between breed and attacks and there have
been lots of very high profile horrific
dog fatalities in the last six months
and they almost invariably in fact it
all involve this one particular route